la montée des extrêmes en france mais
aussi maintenant en allemagne avec l'afd
angoisse nous amis allemands
il ya chez eux une mémoire collective
qui est la mémoire des années 30 il ya
surtout une culpabilité ou en tout cas
le désir que ne recommence jamais les
atroces dérives qui ont amené au nazisme
et il y a la conviction qu'il faut tout
faire par l'europe pour que jamais on ne
retrouve la menace du nationalisme
disait mitterrand
oui le nationalisme c'est la guerre
irako mangala doit qu'elle peut
contribuer à ce combat contre le front
national aujourd'hui en faisaient
lanvaux en faisant en sorte que l'europe
soit une europe forte
ancré dans ses valeurs il s'agit pas
pour elle j'imagine de s'immiscer dans
le débat politique la 17ème rapide est
ici lutte contre le fn c'est ce qu'elle
dit on verra comment elle fait mais je
ne crois pas que ce soit tellement ça
mais c'est surtout faire en sorte de
convaincre à nouveau que l'europe et la
réponse est la solution et qui j'ai joué
je pense que si elle fait ça c'est aussi
parce qu'elle voit que les populismes
justement ne sont pas un privilège
triste privilège français elle voit
quand notre île et ses voisins et braque
autriche à la présidentielle au premier
tour
le cognac foudre a fait 35% elle voit
life des montées et enfants que je pense
qu'il est nécessaire en effet que les
pro européens agissent et pourquoi pas
ensemble - de ce point de vue là je ne
suis pas totalement choqués ou je ne
suis pas choqué parce que je pense que
il ya des valeurs communes que nous
devons défendre
il ya des combats européen ou
paneuropéen il ya les partis qui sont
des partis européens
il y a des valeurs qui sont des valeurs
européennes le combat européen contre le
front national en france à un combat
européen contre le populisme dont la
forme française et le front national
oui et de la même façon que pour ma part
je surveille de près ce qui se passe
dans d'autres pays
j'ai le souhait et j'ai la conviction
que le royaume uni restera dans une
europe unie parce que c'est l'intérêt du
royaume uni parce que c'est l'intérêt de
l'europe parce que toute autre solution
serait perdante pour les uns est
perdante pour les autres et donc san
spoiler la deuxième chose c'est qu'il
n'aura pas échappé
marie le pen comme à tout le monde de le
re unis n'était pas la france
nous nous sommes un pays fondateur de
l'union européenne nous nous sommes un
pays pour laquelle pour lequel la
construction européenne a été construite
c'est bien la réconciliation
franco-allemande qui est là il nous
enfin nous sommes un pays coeur de la
zone euro nous avons non seulement en
commun l'union européenne s'ils ont
dévoilé en interne a aussi l'euro et les
français dont je vois vraiment avec
inquiétude la montée du sentiment
eurosceptique chez eux
les français savent que le rôle et
protège et les défend et les français
sont attachés
quand on perd les paramètres on le voit
attachés à l'euro dont marine le pen se
trompent les français ne voteront jamais
contre l'europe les français n'iront
jamais pour une sortie de l'euro
ce que nous devons faire nous les
pro-européens c'est simplement mieux
montrer en quoi il y a des solutions
européennes qui sont positives pour les
citoyens de ce pays
1 je considère que le principe d'une
négociation commerciale entre les états
unis et l'europe ne doit pas être
écartée car cela peut-être d'intérêt
commun un bon type nous permettrait
permettrait à l'europe de s'ouvrir les
marchés américains et soyons conscients
que les marchés américains sont
aujourd'hui plus fermé que les marchés
européens donc je ne dis pas fermons la
non agression c'est pas bien sûr ensuite
je les dis il faut que ce soit un bon
type
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas d'accord
nous avons des négociations qui ne sont
pas si opaque que ça d'ailleurs et la
commission veille
est ce que tous les états membres soient
informés au fur et à mesure de la façon
dont certains documents publics et ma
collègue notamment 7e un sommet seront
très souvent devant le parlement vient
naturellement il y à une information qui
fait mais aujourd'hui il faut que cette
négociation progresse et elle n'est pas
un stade qui permettent de conclure un
accord car cela a été dit et par
françois hollande et par matthias fekl
et par d'autres
nous ne voulons pas d'une d'un accord
qui compromettrait donne
environnementale qui comprennent des
normes sanitaires qui mettrait en cause
l'existence de notre agriculture ou
qu'ils ne permettraient pas l'accès aux
marchés publics
voilà un certain nombre de conditions
donc sur le principe nous nous opposons
pas la négociation de tête conduite de
manière extrêmement serré et solide en
fonction de nos intérêts stratégie est
ce que c'est possible aujourd'hui est ce
que là est ce que les états unis ne
cherchent pas à imposer leur point de
vue l'aciériste le jazz pas comme disent
les des facteurs à mettre l'europe sous
tutelle moi j'ai pris un petit peu de
recul avec certaines passions nationales
et j'imagine que si j'étais américain et
je voyais le document européen
je me dirais non européens ils ont plein
de lignes rouges ils veulent pas nous
aider nous comprennent pas c'est le
propre d'une négociation et donc moi je
suis pas très choqué par le fait que
aujourd'hui les deux parties ne soit pas
vraiment en train de se rencontrer mais
l'europe premiers points d'avance le
principe ne l'écartons pas de deuxième
point il faut un bon type il faut
beaucoup de conditions et troisième
point ces conditions aujourd'hui ne sont
pas remplies la question qui est nouveau
en nous c'est la question du temps parce
qu'il reste peu de temps pour conclure
éventuellement ce tic puisque vous savez
que l'administration américaine
eric celle de barack obama s'achève
début novembre
donc voilà le compte à rebours est très
serré et quand le président dit
aujourd'hui ce serait non
je suis d'accord aujourd'hui on n'y est
pas je veux le dire différemment mais il
faut en même temps que les négociations
se poursuivent que le travail c'est en
tous les cas on ne croit pas un barack
obama avec en fin de mandat moon a
rappelé mais il faut mener une
négociation très serré nous verrons très
conscients de nos intérêts avec nos
propres lignes rouges très ferme un bon
type ou pathétique où le coeur de
l'europe c'est la zone horreur
il faut que le coeur la zone euro soit
plus fort battre plus fort aujourd'hui
on a construit une romy est une union
monétaire
il nous manque encore l'union économique
et l'union politique c'est la raison
pour laquelle moi je propose un mise de
l'économie et des finances de la zone
euro qui serait membre de la commission
responsable devant le parlement européen
avec un budget pour la zone euro
vous avez présenté tout à l'heure les
prévisions de printemps de la commission
européenne les pressions
macroéconomiques apparemment à nouveau
la commission européenne voit la
croissance française un petit peu
moindre que celle qui est annoncée par
le gouvernement
comment pouvez vous expliquer cette
différence est ce qui d'abord l'écart
est faible nous nous voyons en 2003 le
français voit 1,5
j'ajoute que nous n'avons pas intégré
dans nos chiffres les résultats du
premier trimestre qui sont plutôt un peu
meilleur que ce que corporelle nos
propres prévisions
et s'il ya un bonus je dirais tant mieux
et de toute façon cette croissance de
l'économie française reste légèrement
inférieur à la moyenne de la zone euro à
2 6%
pour nous cette année et demi pensions
l'an prochain nous aurions à 8 7% pour
la france quand paris n'a pas à se
vanter
il s'agit pas de se vanter ou pas dans
tes un peu de science fiction
si on pose la question de savoir si ça
va mieux puisque c'est un peu du mal au
mode je dirais pas que ça va plutôt
mieux plutôt mieux parce que vous avez
d'une part la croissance qui est
maintenant reparti avec une consommation
intérieure qui tient bon avec un
investissement qui repart et on attend
sans doute le zeste de confiance
supplémentaire
vous avez des finances publiques dont la
situation s'améliore
on ne viendra j'imagine mais oui je
pense tout à fait jouable à condition
que les finances publiques soient
maîtrisées et que les engagements pris
soient respectés
je pense jouable de passer en deçà de 3%
en 2010 est enfin enfin enfin troisième
chose
troisième chose permettait que je le jeu
le jeu évoque parce que c'est tout à
fait important je crois que le chômage
devrait reculer en 2016 de 10 4% du pib
à 10 2% du pib et donc je parle de la
dépression de la commission aujourd'hui
dont l'amélioration
une amélioration qui ne permettra pas de
résoudre tous les problèmes de la
société française notamment sur le
chômage
on attend sans doute plus il faudra
continuer mais enfin il compte des
bonnes nouvelles arrivent il ne faut pas
je pense les négliger
par ailleurs nous allons examiner en
2017 au plus tôt en 2016 le projet de
budget pour 2010 est de la france et
nous demanderons nous demanderons là
nous demandons avec beaucoup de fermeté
que les engagements qui ont été pris
dans le pacte de stabilité soit du tas
que ce budget de manière crédible montre
quel est le chemin qui nous amène en
dessous de 3%
est ce que je dis ce n'est pas on va y
arriver je suis pas français à ce point
je ne suis pas schizophrène du doubs je
dis que si il y à des efforts je dis que
si les finances publiques sont sérieuses
je dis que si les dépenses
supplémentaires affectées avec dc je dis
que si les baisses d'impôts éventualité
reprise en réplique n'aime pas été
affirmatif sont financés dans ces
conditions la wii passé de 3,2 à en
dessous de 3%
c'est jouable et quand je m'exprime
ainsi re ca deviens pas la parole
personnelle c'est la parole de la
commission et quand je ne veux pas
qu'ils aient une suspicion je suis pas à
une sorte comme ça de le france est
transposée à bruxelles je suis le
commissaire chargé des affaires
économiques sens hier par ailleurs
français il quand je me lève c'est
jouable
c'est ce que pour la commission elle ne
pense pas que certains ne pensent pas
que c'est fait elle pense que c'est
jouable
si la france est sérieuse et vous
demanderont et les sérieuses aujourd'hui
quand vous étiez vous mais quand je
compte quand je regarde le chemin qu'ils
aient un terme et la juge dans les
décisions l'aller l'aider quand on signe
des chèques là mais tous les jours
encore une fois ces chèques c'est que
quand je suis devenu misé finances
j'avais dit à mon prédécesseur
commissaire la commission fixe les fins
nous fixons les moyens je n'ai pas a
expliqué à françois hollande ou à michel
sapin roi manuel valls les choix qui
doit le faire en revanche ce que je dois
faire moi c'est le rappelait qu'il ya
des règles communes et que s'il ya des
dépenses supplémentaires
il devrait avoir des économies
correspondante s'il ya des baisses
d'impôt elles devront être financés
or de l'unité de la gauche il n'y a pas
d'accès au pouvoir la deuxième leçon
c'est qu'il faut aussi une cohérence
intellectuelle et idéologique qui
tiennent compte des leçons du réel car
sinon on se fracasse sur ce mur qui a
été le mur de l'argent à l'époque et qui
est le mur de la réalité
et chaque fois que la gauche a fait des
réformes qui elles sont restées mais
chaque fois que la gauche a voulu faire
des réformes qui se heurtait au réel à
ce moment là il était obligé de reculer
et donc il faut éviter de se renier ça
c'est la troisième leçon on en a besoin
on a besoin c'est logique sociale
démocrate
la réformisme qu'ils soient ancrés dans
le réel des réformistes qui soit
également européen mais d'un réformisme
ils partirent tous vos amis du parti
socialiste sans doute sans doute sans
doute mais c'est aussi c'est aussi c'est
aussi renoncer aux valeurs de tours je
ne sais pas qui dit cela on va vous le
dire vous allez me dire parce que je
suis moi j'ai ce grand privilège vous
aime pas être tous les jours dans les
débats le parti socialiste est ce que
les bombes avoir tous les fossoyeurs de
ce quinquennat terme moscovici août et
non ceux qui ce qu'ils expriment des
opinions ils ne votent pas les textes
qui est compliqué pour une majorité
en même temps ils ne représentent pas
les l'immense majorité des socialistes
et des sociaux démocrates
ce quinquennat est un quinquennat dont
il appartient au président de la
république de démontrer qu'il a été
utile et puis ensuite on verra comment
cela se porte la campagne électorale
mais les accusations
bien des présentations il me semble je
m'exprime personnel que les explique des
accusations de trahison ou de
renoncement sont sans fondement et que
ce n'est pas une façon au sein de la
gauche de mener le débat
donc vous ne comprenez pas que certains
puissent être heurtée du fait que
françois hollande se soit éloigné à ce
point par exemple du discours du bourget
on le cite souvent de proposer parfois
des lois finalement qui satisfont plus
la droite que la gauche l'a long travail
par exemple
au départ elle a quand même plus étaient
applaudis sur les bancs de la droite
puissent applaudir le comprenez moi de
là je suis une position un peu
inconfortable ce que je commissaire
européen je ne peux me faire ni le
critique ni l'avocat françois loos mais
je n'ai pas envie je n'ai pas envie et
je ne peux pas je dirais simplement ce
que je crois sur le plan des principes
je pense qu'une gauche de transformation
qu'une gauche de réformes qu une gauche
dure et elle qu'une gauche européenne
qu'une gauche sociale-démocrate qu'une
auch rénové et bien l'avenir pour cette
famille politique qu'elle a besoin de
rester elle même qu'elle a besoin de
rester authentique qu'elles vont rester
fidèle à ses valeurs qu'elle a besoin
aussi de tenir compte du réel est-ce que
cela s'est passé pendant ces cinq ans je
pense que honnêtement il ya une
tentative sincère pour le faire avec de
vrais résultats avec de vraies réformes
qu'il ya sans doute eu aussi des choses
qui n'ont pas fonctionné qu'il faut
faire ce d'examen prémices à donner un
certain nombre d'exemples je vous
randonnez de prison plus qu'on a
abandonné mais ce n'est pas à moi de le
faire encore mais ce qu'on a à l'heure
du bilan c'est vrai que manuel valls a
pointé un certain nombre d'erreurs dans
ce sens avait une campagne électorale
est proche
c'est ce moment privilégié où il ya
cette rencontre avec le pays ce grand
débat où il ya d'une part le bilan est
nécessaire il nous est fait le chef de
l'état et la majorité c'est l'opposition
mais aussi par le chef d'état est pas la
majorité mu même et je crois comprendre
que françois hollande réfléchit aussi
lui-même ce qui a fonctionné et ce qui
n'a pas mal fonctionné tupuailai aussi
et c'est une deuxième dimension qui est
essentiel c'est la dimension du projet
inventaire avant même la fin du
quinquennat ou à la fin du quinquennat
je n'ai pas la sensation quand je
rencontre françois hollande de trouver
quelqu'un need a battu il ne l'est pas
sanogo combatif il a toujours été
il sait ce que c'est que la politique
ait de l'expérience il ya du métier il a
beaucoup de sang froid
mais ce n'est pas non plus un homme
auteur satisfait je pense qu'il est
aussi capable lui même de se dire voilà
ça ça fonctionne et ça ça n'a pas
fonctionné
et s'il était candidat il s'est sans
doute que le projet devrait être à la
fois le prolongement de ce qui a été
fait et aussi sans doute un peu
différent ça c'est la propre le propre
d'un bon politique et je pense que en
toute hypothèse qu'on peut lui faire
beaucoup de critiques on avait donné des
avis les tarbais solution qui se prépare
non mais vous l'avez rencontrée je dis
ça je dis simplement que kele monde
impression j'ai pas dû seulement hier
c'est à l'homme fait chaud chaud là que
je connais bien depuis 35 ans j'ai été
effectivement le directeur de sa
campagne présidentielle
je ne suis pas son porte parole je ne
sais pas quelles sont ces attentions
mais mon sentiment c'est que c'est un
homme qui est combatif qui est fier de
ce qu'il a fait et qui est aussi un
homme lucide est candidat c'est pas ça
vous le savez tous les gars vous dites
on verra comment les choses tournent
pendant la campagne électorale
je voudrais une autre impression plus
aisés comme ça on est sous la vème
république
la logique elle s'est toujours appliqué
et que le président n'aurait plus que
sortant se représente à la fois pour
défendre son bilan et pour porter un
nouveau projet ça ne marche pas toujours
pâques c'est vrai je je je je pense que
la logique tout de même c'est aussi de
se donner du temps et que justement
parce qu'il ya le quinquennal
quinquennat pourquoi at il été fait on
pouvait se dire deux fois sept ans c'est
trop et d'ailleurs à part françois
mitterrand personnes a fait deux fois 7
ans et les dernières années 80 les
années compliquées et donc on s'est dit
le quinquennat pourquoi pas ce qu'on
peut faire deux fois cinq ans
c'est en gros le rythme qui existe dans
nos démocraties donc l'existant du
quinquennat va plutôt renforcé l'idée de
deux candidatures d'un homme à la
présidence de la république le s'est
toujours passé le président encore une
fois je ne fais qu'une observation film
historique qui nous paraît cohérente le
fléchissement de nos institutions
la coalition elle peut être obligé si
d'aventuré madame le pen était au 2e
tour en 2017
certains sondages beaucoup de sondages
en réalité le disent alors à ce moment
là il serait compliqué pour ceux qui
aimeraient élu un président deuxième
tour de dire on s'ignore
mais ce serait le résultat des élections
et ce serait forcément un combat ça ne
peut pas c'est une confusion qui précède
l'élection
c'est en tout cas une hypothèse
envisagée il ya pas si emmanuel macron
manuel valls dit aussi un peu la même
chose que son ministre je ne veux pas
les départager mais ils ne disent pas
tout à fait la même chose
jean christophe cambadélis ne disent pas
la même chose mais disent pas la même
chose dans l'es10 pas la même chose
parce que lundi voilà ni droite ni
gauche ont fait quelque chose avant
c'est le sens de son mouvement
l'audi je suis de gauche et je peux être
amené à travailler avec d'autres dans le
cas d'une coalition ce qui est déjà plus
classique
nous verrons cambadélis a dépassé aussi
les parties publiques et en toute
hypothèse que ce qui est important et ça
c'est ma position constante c'est que la
gauche aurait neuf il ya évidemment une
satisfaction par rapport à la gauche en
france il ya besoin de modernisation
il ya besoin de théorie mais il ya
besoin de théoriser ce qui a été fait il
ya un besoin de conceptualiser il ya
besoin d'avancer dans la gauche par
rapport à l'europe de dette
enfin complètement européen et de
construire également une europe qui soit
davantage marqué par les idées de la
gauche veut faire des propositions
soutiens démocrates mais j'y travaille
moi avec martin schulz le président du
parlement européen avec matteo renzi et
donc voilà je crois plus que notre
avenir c'est la modernisation de la
gauche
la refondation de la gauche la
rénovation de la gauche que la fa 10
mans de la gauche ou la fin de la gauche
assène françois hollande qu'elle incarne
ça on verra verser page et c'est pas moi
de le dire
je dis simplement que quand je vois le
président la république je vois un homme
combatif